[Musique]
affûté tranchant lourds ou légers de
type allemands ou japonais
les couteaux sont stylés et il est
nombreux l'épicerie métaux banc d'essai
dit couteau de chef avec des lames de 20
cm à moins de 150 dollars testé par chef
le couteau de chef c'est vraiment la
base de l'outillage du cuisinier
professionnel comme celui à la maison
c'est vraiment le look talk on se sert
pour découper les légumes pour émincer
pour ciseler les herbes entre autres
pour découper des poissons des viandes
c'est le prolongement de sa main donc
d'aider des chefs vont préférer des plus
tôt plus âgés plus léger un peu plus du
type japonais alors que certains vont
préférer couteau plus plus épais plus
massif plus lourd on peut là c'est un
peu plus salement un couteau comme celui
là c'est vraiment un modèle plus
classique de couteaux européens avec la
lame le talon lapointe la jonction entre
le manche est la langue qu'on appelle la
mitre et celui-ci est muni de ce qu'on
appelle en traversant qui donne la
solidité qui donne la rigidité hôpitaux
aussi et qui permet de maintenir un
équilibre dans la main la prise en main
c'est peut-être le plus important donc
les essayer voir si on est confortable
avec la prise évidemment un bon fils une
bonne rétention du fils donc en
matériaux lot de qualité c'est sûr que
ça va aider la longueur de la lame ou
s'il a menti pic puis le dégagement au
niveau du talon on va avoir un talent
qui est quand même assez assez haut pour
permettre certains mouvements de hachage
le sillage des messages j'apprécie quand
même ce type de couteau lors où est ce
que la masse du poteau va finalement
nous a aidés à découper certains
aliments vont un peu participé au
mouvement des opérations comme celle de
trancher la tête d'un poisson
demande à mon avis
une lame qui est quand même assez
assez pesant
notre ch est ensuite testé le victorinox
pour finalité ce poisson à l'époque mal
c'est impeccable malgré l'élégance du
couteau et du foro ricardo le chef a
émis des réserves quant elles se mangent
glissant et sa cambrure
j'ai trouvé l'angle du fils à se
prononcer donc cette cambrure assez
prononcé trop à mon goût en moins et ce
qui fait que lorsque j'ai testé avec des
herbes entre autres lorsque j'ai six
lire ce que j'ai aimé c'est bien souvent
le y avait des disputes accordé en
anglais exactement mais combien oui mais
un bon fils sont préférés pour
travailler le poisson le plus cher du
lot le marché global effet également
d'un seul matériau mais il est comme
alvéolé donc il ya vraiment une
meilleure prise au niveau du manche ou
six sept longueurs de l'anglais nous
permet de faire des coupes en continu
nous permet de devenir des poupées
certains produits sans devoir faire des
allers-retours le couteau mac a dit sue
je trouve que les angles au niveau du
talon de la lame son trait acéré donc je
me suis imaginé la m16 des oignons pour
120 litres de soupe à l'oignon par
exemple et je suis sûr que j'aurais
problème en développant une ampoule
contrairement à plusieurs vincent aime
travailler avec des manches messier par
contre pour des tâches très répétitives
ça peut être inconfortable lorsqu'il ya
un petit peu d'humidité la sueur sur le
mange ça peut devenir un peu agressant
pour la main je prenais plusieurs
collègues qui vont préférer par contre
des couteaux avec un manche en bois je
connais personne qui préfère les plus
tôt entre les marches en plastique qu'on
est membre pourquoi plastique c'est pas
un coup de coeur je voudrais que c'est
probablement au niveau de la prise en
main c'est plus ou moins agréables ils
seront peut-être des petites aspérités
aussi au niveau du plastique dans les
finitions qui sont moins bien réussi
j'ai découvert d'ailleurs dans ce modèle
si l' espèce de petit trou là où peuvent
se loger la nourriture
vincent a testé deux modèles de la
maison ce wheeling à commencer par le
modèle qu'on leur ait dit je voudrais
que ça pourrait être beaucoup plus
facile que ça je devrais pas devoir
faire des allers retours comme ça ça
s'appelle un nom bien aller ne va pas
bien du tout même constat pour les
welling tradition les zones sont très
acérées très inconfortable également le
marché très petit où hélène il fonde
tout comme la plupart des marques car
ils font du
modèle d'entrée de gamme jusqu'à des
couteaux très très très haut de gamme
donc je sais que souligne font de très
très bon couteau mais celui là que pour
le banc d'essai le
manioc rutabaga tomates nous avons testé
les couteaux sur des aliments coriace ou
bien mûres ça c'est le victorinox fibrox
un marchand plastique particulièrement
tu diras pas mais il est très
confortable c'est un couteau que moi
j'aime beaucoup en fait par contre avec
le cuisinant que je vous fais peut-être
genre permet la caméra donc l'aiguisage
initial est médiocre vraiment le terme
en mai médiocre c'est mal réalisés et au
niveau de la coupe on n'a pas un scoop
qui n' est très difficile de trancher je
dois mettre donc falloir beaucoup de
force à l'opposé un [ __ ] rno qui coûte
le même prix que le cuisine armes à
l'opposé je sais pas c'est à l'opposé
mais
willy en fait le traversin beaucoup plus
fin beaucoup plus raisonnable je dirais
il est un peu plus léger son équilibre
en main est vraiment plus agréable sa
conception au niveau du manche d'essai
des couteaux qui sont très similaires
visiblement celui ci entre autres à ma
grande surprise est à la fois
performants confortable mais on a
quelque chose de
beaucoup plus facile
on a un véritable tranchant c'est
étonnant le coeur absolument j'avoue que
j'ai dû changer mon fusil d épaule
initialement j'étais celle ci que je
suis confondues
avons délivré son verdict le chef à
quelques conseils il ya de très bon
couteau qui se vante de fort prix mais
qui ne conviennent pas nécessairement à
la main tout le monde donc je pense que
c'est important de laisser y très
important très important aussi de ne
jamais mettre ses couteaux ou la baisse
non les détergents auxi de la lame et la
chaleur excessive abîme 90 on lave à la
main on les suit on le range idéalement
dans un fourreau dans un tiroir où il se
repose il rentrera pas en contact un
choc avec d'autres d'autres outils
certainement le rapport qualité-prix de
l'epad ernaux se distingue largement qui
n'ont qualités pures et agrément de
coupe je voudrais que j'ai un petit
faible pour le global et pour les deux
victorinox